well thanks for having me here this is
like a really strange strange thing for
me I would have never imagined that I
would be here talking to you all at
Stanford but I'm really excited so we're
gonna start from the beginning so I'm
gonna give talk a little bit more about
some technical stuff that I don't get
the chance to talk about because I'm
excited to have an audience that could
you know call me out on some of maybe
the bad choices that we've made or the
things that I'm not thinking about in
the right way so after we finish up with
our more questions and I want to hear
what you guys really think so I'm Dave
Roush work the founder and CEO of next
thinkoh along with Thomas Dekker and
Gustavo Huber we started this experiment
about two years ago almost to the day so
let's go for it so as we talked about
we're gonna talk about chip the world's
first $9 computer this one right here is
it super small 60 by 40 millimeters this
launched on Kickstarter in May of this
year along with these little adapters
let you connect it to displays battery
packs and this thing called pocket chip
which makes chip portable it adds a
keyboard a screen and a battery and you
just pop chip in and use it kind of as a
portable computer now the thing I'll say
about chip is it's completely
open-source hardware and what that means
is the schematics Bill of Materials
files the data sheets the bootloader the
kernel that runs on it's everything
that's you need to make chip is
available to download on our website
Doc's dot next think oh so that means
that you can't buy one today but you
could if you were so inclined make one
which is pretty cool
when it launched on Kickstarter the
thing that was really incredible is that
we had thirty nine thousand five hundred
and sixty different people purchase chip
from I believe a hundred and eight
different countries and for a company
that at the time was nine people in a
garage in Oakland California this was a
pretty exciting thing because it meant
that we weren't completely crazy that
this thing
we wanted and we needed other people
also wanted and may be needed so one of
my favorite things about this entire
project is the things that people are
going to do with it and the community
that's what it's really all about these
were tweets these were from a while ago
we get them all the time now and it's
and it's just so awesome of all the
different things that people want to do
with chip you know the question to ask
is when a computer cost as much as a
burrito what can you do with it we're
talking about computers that are
basically free and things that were once
absurd now become reasonable so I
remember which ones these are everybody
will robot that's pretty good 3d printer
garage door opener I don't think if I
have it up here but there's like three
different people during the campaign
that said they wanted to send chip to
space we've had people in school
districts that want access to chips so
kids can have access to affordable
computers now the question is like we
didn't set out necessarily to make the
world's cheapest computer it's something
that kind of happened and we'll talk
about that so this is chip I was just
showing it to you it's 60 by 40
millimeters it's got Wi-Fi b/g/n
bluetooth 4 gigabytes of NAND flash
storage a 1 gigahertz SOC with all
manner of things which we'll talk about
512 Meg's of RAM it's got a GPU it can
run off of a battery it has both USB
on-the-go support and a full sized USB
port both USB 2.0 and it has composite
video out headphone out all this roof
things so out of the box chip here does
computer things which we like to say if
people say oh it's a computer what does
it do well it does computer things you
can play games you can surf the web you
can learn to code you can put it into
your projects you can send us a space
whatever you want computer things so
there's this song by the Talking Heads
if you're familiar with it once in a
lifetime David Byrne says how did I get
here
and I'm gonna take you through step by
step as mr. Byrne does and
show you where this all came to be and
in the process you will see how the
architecture of this computer came
together because I read the description
when they you know Andy and Dennis came
to me I said hey what this thing I'm
like sure yeah can I get really
technical there's like yeah absolutely
so the question and the thing to think
about here and what's really the most
interesting thing about the technical
architecture of chip is how we picked
what's there right like you see this
right and you're it looks it's a thing
now you could people all over the planet
have them we've shipped thousands of
them already and you know how do we end
up with this particular Wi-Fi chipset or
how do we end up with you know having a
jst connector for a battery or why is
there one big USB port in one small USB
port why are the headers the shape that
they are whine and flash right like why
not an SD card why not
MMC well why do we make these choices
and I would love to say that we just
sort of woke up one day and there was
you know spoof we hit our heads on a
toilet and then all of a sudden like you
know flux capacitor chip was just born
right it wasn't wasn't quite like that
so let's say let's get into it so the
story goes back to this thing here the
nine dollar computer it started as an
art project and it's kind of gotten out
of control since then and the art
project was called the crank it was done
in November of 2013 at a party in San
Francisco that was the one of the first
art exhibitions for animated gif artists
it was done by Gaston which is amazing
arts organization in the city if you've
never been to their events you need to
go and josette who I was curating the
show said to me hey like could you make
an animated gif photobooth and I was
like sure yeah we have anything else you
need it's like nah do whatever you want
and naturally I did and so the crank was
a big wooden box kind of like Moy
bridges original video camera with a big
hand crank on the side of it right it
was made out of a mechanism from a
ratchet strap the hand crank from my
poor Lex coffee grinder that I use going
camping a Raspberry Pi a camera module a
rotary encoder some wires and it it was
just a on a tripod picture of it right
that's what it looks like just like a
laser cut box that I made in my studio
no instructions were provided it was set
on a tripod at this gallery and people
had to figure out how it worked and you
would turn the crank right people would
first were like looking into it they
didn't know what it did and then you
would do stuff in front of the camera
and it wouldn't make an animated gif and
when it made this animated gif it would
be projected on the side of a building
about 50 feet high which is sort of a
big reveal right so if you do something
really absurd it's really really big and
it's really fun so made this thing and
I'll tell you it barely worked right
save for the help of my very close
artist friends and some last-minute
hacking and getting an ssh and SFTP
library to work and python and all these
things it just barely worked but the
good news was people really really had
fun with it so this is Gabe and Ryan who
still work with us on occasion today but
they're the guys that helped me get it
working at the last minute and this is
us being really excited you can see me
running at the last second and so we
know how it worked but then after a
while there was this line of like
hundreds of people doing this and so
they started to figure out how it worked
and do these really awesome inventive
things I have no idea where this
watering-can came from or why he's
wearing a fuzzy vest or whatever this is
and again like it was something so
simple and people had so much fun with
it and then we're like hey like can we
change the rate at which it captures
frames can we you know can I save them
to my phone right can I turn the crank
backwards and run the whole thing in
Reverse all these ideas people had and I
was just like whoa scope creep like not
happening this was so hard to do right
it seems so easy and so straightforward
look let's just capture some frames
let's listen to a rotary encoder and
let's make an animated gif and then
let's project it right so as soon as
this this happened is weird experience I
made something and people were like wow
this is really cool you should make a
kit do a Kickstarter or something like
that's a terrible idea
that's gonna be so much work so I call
my two closest friends who are also
worked in the world for the installation
art and making wacky blinking stuff is
as Gus likes to say so that's Gus right
here on my left and that's Thomas on the
right and I said guys like let's make
let's make it easier for people to make
a camera let's make it so that we can
experiment all these like
is that people have let's make that a
thing so it's not like something you
have to figure out and in the spirit of
open source right like everything that I
do now I'm standing on the shoulders of
giants I take the work that other people
have done and I combine different things
together and I add my own sort of
special flavor to it and then I had this
amazing new thing that wouldn't be
possible if I wasn't able to build off
of other people's work and so we started
talking about it and we're all huge
camera nerds they were like we should do
this we should make a camera and not a
kit let's make a camera let's make a $99
animated gif camera that's built
entirely on open architecture the
electronics in the software so that the
next person that wants to make one of
these wacky things are wants to
experiment can do it without all the
pain and hassle that we had and maybe
people would buy it just to make
animated gifts like just for fun and
then they say hey I want to change the
way it works and they would crack it
open and they wouldn't learn how it
worked and it was a chance for us to
change this idea of what people thought
a product leaders and hackers and folks
like us looked like but why didn't we
have something that felt as awesome and
was as well put together and designed as
the things you could buy in a store yeah
so where was I $99 right that sounds
doable right like show of hands like
yeah yeah sure right you can buy a
digital camera it like Target for 40
bucks right it's got to be some way like
you you think like oh when I make a
prototype then I'm just gonna like scale
to mass production I'm gonna go to China
it's really the magic thing is gonna
happen and on the other side of this
Chinese experience I'm gonna have this
massively scalable product it's $99 and
then it's gonna be a thing and so we've
all Thomas kustanai we've all worked in
tons of companies who worked in startups
we've built all manner of wacky stuff
launched software projects we've never
really built a thing that you could buy
that had hardware and software and all
these different pieces that you could
take out of the box and would just kind
of work and the chasm and it is a chasm
between something that barely works as
an art installation and something that
someone can buy with no
context and then make work is enormous
so there's just think accelerator which
is a really crazy awesome thing started
by Cyril
Epis Wyler and Shawna Sullivan in this
they have adventure fun and they like
look like people are trying to build
hardware and you got to do it in change
in China and since we made stuff we were
always reading you know like bunny
flanks post about going to wash on Bay
you guys know we're watching Bay is Shen
Jen heard about this who's been ok right
one okay you all need to go right if you
can sit here and listen let me talk for
45 minutes you want to go to Shen Jen
especially right now crazy crazy things
are happening and so we went to hacks
and basically from the time that we said
let's make a kit let's make it a product
let's make it $99 it was like late
November so right after Thanksgiving
last minute we sent an application and
we're like hey I'm gonna make this
camera you know like it's going to be a
gifts gonna be super cool it's gonna be
a hundred bucks we just go to China like
January like three weeks later we just
take off we go to China we live in China
for six months so we're here with this
little laser and ever get to do this
yeah so there were here in Guangdong
province where is this map yeah there we
go Shan Jen yeah it's the Hong Kong cool
so we got there and we live there and we
see watchon Bay like entire buildings
full of crazy components everything you
want to buy from digi-key you want to
get it at a frequent Sparkfun and it's
all like basically free and you can get
it the same day right it's crazy it's
the most awesome thing you will ever see
if you're into these kind of things
different conversation and the answer
the answer is it turns out it's really
easy to buy a hundred of something but
as soon as you try and buy a thousand or
ten thousand of something that becomes a
huge issue and we'll talk about that in
a second so we're inch engine for six
months and what do we do we build a ton
of cameras right
every week we build a new camera right
we have been using the Raspberry Pi to
power this thing because it's what's
around it was great and it was like okay
we're gonna try and figure it out build
more cameras build more cameras you can
see this wooden one
which we made before we left and then
these plastic ones this is blue guy in
the front which we're going to talk
about we tried everything we tried all
kinds of different SSC's all kinds of
different security cameras because we
hack them different processors some dev
kits sensor modules all this stuff just
couldn't figure it out so we ended up so
we ended up with this right so this is
Auto you can see one right here right
this is real thing we made these I know
there are a couple of backers here and a
Stephanie has one so this is a hackable
animated Giff camera and if I hadn't
just spent the last 15 minutes telling
you that it was made by a bunch of
artists who wanted to help people hack
their cameras you would say yeah it
looks like a film camera it has no
screen on the back it's got a strap on
it like kind of it looks like a thing
well something happened when we were
over there and the Raspberry Pi
foundation released this thing called
the compute module which looks a bit
like this right so who knows what a
Raspberry Pi is everybody awesome cool
so I think I have one in here all right
yeah cool that's my pie I'll be so they
came out this thing right and so we'll
go back a slide we build these really
big kind of cumbersome cameras right and
we got really excited right this turns
into this you're like awesome it's gonna
get cheaper it's gonna get smaller the
solution we have it now because we've
been building with this the whole time
now we want to productize it if you will
turn it into a thing and we can do it so
let's talk briefly about what Auto does
because this is gonna frame the entire
context for why we're here so I'm
actually just gonna turn it on which is
kind of fun so turn it on oh look at
that it's already running okay so it's
got a little crank here right and you're
in the menu system here and if you want
to make an animated gif you just go to
the gift mode not still you click the
shutter and then you just turn this guy
like this all right and then you crank
it in reverse and you've just made an
animated gif right the camera creates a
wireless network and then you can join
that from your phone and you can browse
all the images and well after I have
some time to finish this up we'll play
you guys couldn't tell me how broken it
is in different ways and what you change
and all that but luckily it's hackable
so you can help me fix it so you'll
notice that this this sort of behavior
it implies a lot of things going on
under the hood so let's take a look so
we ended up with this with this compute
module right but that's it's missing all
the other bits so we had to build things
like how do you power it right a product
when you put when you plug it in it
needs to charge it needs to run off of a
battery how does that work you need
Wi-Fi all right how do you get actual
Wi-Fi to run on the thing you need the
ability to communicate with external
peripherals maybe you need more USB
ports you need some way to connect
sensors like rotary encoders and buttons
you need to have a way to connect the
camera itself right it turns out just
going to build that that board on the
top is one of the first dev boards that
we built what's so hard right it's so
incredibly hard and you know does
anybody here ever designed like high
frequency RF stuff with impedance match
traces sure there's a couple people
right I should have called you guys like
a year ago right and the thing is like
doing this high frequency stuff like we
started as an art project this is a year
ago we're already now like eight months
later and we're you know sort of neck
deep in all these EDA tools trying to
figure out how we can actually make this
thing do the thing that we want and
we're so focused on doing it it all
seemed it didn't really seem that crazy
at the time that we were building a four
layer PCB with all this these random
accessories and having to spec these
connectors and then we had to make it
smaller because it had to fit in the
camera right well so this is the dev
board they give you when you buy it
which is like I don't know two hundred
and fifty bucks and this is the
prototype board notice that has a
real-time clock and a power supply as
well we had to add that and then that's
the production board and I have one of
those here right so this is what's in
the camera and you guys can see that
play with it later and the little module
snaps in right here but you know what
really is kind of unfortunate this took
almost eight months to develop it's not
a lot smaller than this
right but we still had to do it because
we needed everything to be on one piece
and we needed it you know there's all
kinds of interesting is like we added a
USB port on the back because when you
build consumer products and you need
Wi-Fi it needs to be FCC certified so
what do you do you don't have any money
it's you're just four people in a garage
in Oakland you're like let's just use
pre certified USB modules and we'll just
plug them in so we'll put this little
USB port on the back so we went through
all that and you know we're going to
talk too much about it today but
everything I've talked about I haven't
mentioned software right how does the
thing boot how does it turn on fast how
do you get it to actually do the things
that you want it to do
right well the camera runs Linux but man
like unit you've all used Linux you know
like you can't just give somebody a box
that has a Linux computer in it and
expect them to do anything with it so
there's a whole other host of challenges
there so you can see like this is Gus
inch engine with a complete a
programmable load and a power supply and
trying to figure out why this five rail
power supply that we've designed is not
quite right and the SOC is browning out
when the Wi-Fi starts on boot because
this is current terrible amount of
inrush current he's trying to make sure
that the batteries work here we have
this USB charge load testing thing it's
like we just want to make a camera that
makes animated gifts come on people like
why do we have to do all of this but you
know we did and so it brings us to this
right so I told you about Wi-Fi talking
about bluetooth battery charging power
like storage we didn't talk about we
talked about the software it's got a
boot fast right it can't be like some SD
card right it has to it has to boot
really fast and it can't just corrupt
all of a sudden right if somebody's
photos if they just if you bought a
camera at Best Buy
right newest Nikon camera and you go out
and you shoot all these photos and then
you come home and none of them are there
what are you gonna do right you're gonna
be really angry right it's sort of like
step one it has to work so we went
through all of this Shiki nuri really to
create something that had all of the
things that we needed to build the
camera and we started asking ourselves
and our friends and lots of people
building products and just doing
projects other artists hey have you guys
like ever gotten Wi-Fi to work on your
boards and they're like no right anybody
here a Raspberry Pi like have you done
put a USB Wi-Fi adapter who's done that
me yeah does just work when you plug it
in no not so far yeah that's crazy right
like that it doesn't just work
what about SD cards do the SD cards just
work not always yeah yeah well there you
go and so we just said to ourselves
everyone has the same problems everyone
needs the same things we've already
learned all this stuff against our
better judgment let's just put it all
into one thing right and let's see what
happens well right around that same time
the Kickstarter campaign launches right
for auto we'll go back to auto so we can
look at that some more so we launched
this thing it was a huge sensation on
the internet like we sold as many units
as we had articles written about it
which was awesome for us we're like this
is great but we made around I would say
seventy thousand dollars and sold about
three hundred and fifty cameras and all
this stuff I've talked about right like
that's a lot of effort for so few units
and so we're like great maybe
distributors will pick it up and we can
sell them all over the world and then we
can you know amortize this development
cost and we'll have a business
well the distributor's calm they say one
of the more terrifying things I've heard
in recent memory which is what is your
wholesale price right and so when you
build consumer electronics they teach
you at hack seller ATAR that your retail
price should be two and a half to three
times your bomb cost we sold autos for a
hundred and forty bucks
149 for the first people at bottom and
then two hundred and forty nine dollars
for the people that bought them later in
the campaign does anyone hear what a
venture a guess what it costs to make a
single auto camera like you can safely
say we spent at least 249 dollars to
make each one
that we sold right the thing to say is
we couldn't sell it we've had people
that wanted it they say what's your
wholesale price can you sell them to us
for a hundred bucks
well we can't do it right and then we
could sell them to you for 249 and do
all right but no one's gonna buy a $700
animated gift camera right that's crazy
doesn't it you said it was really fun at
100 150 bucks to her bucks but 7 or nah
that's nuts so we had to make it cheaper
and following those rules right we
looked at what it took to make Auto and
we said okay if you're gonna spend it's
gonna be a $99 product go back to the
dream how do we make that and it's got
to be three times bomb costs you have
$33 with which to build an animated gif
camera so when I said how hard is it to
build a mega camera yeah not so bad
who here thinks that they can build a
$33 animated gif camera there's some
number where it works sure there's some
the other thing is here of these things
like brewery encoders and things like
that on there that are kind of
non-standard things to have been like
high-volume consumer electronics and
that also leads to higher assembly cause
we need people wiring them and stuff
like that of course we're talking
exclusively bond cost here let's just
let's dismiss the foil load cost of
assembly sure point of order in case
people bomb is bill of material oh thank
you so much yeah there's too many
acronyms in this business so it doesn't
make sense just say so so well the
punchline is 33 bucks you know typical
case got a little packaging you gotta
write the manual let's forget about
paying for the software for a second
you've got about ten dollars to build
the computer right you need Wi-Fi any
Bluetooth you need battery charging and
power you need storage you need RAM you
need an SOC it's got to run Linux and
it's got to just work and it's got to
cost less than ten bucks so that's how
you get chip
right you start by building a camera you
try and do it even in low volumes you
talk about 5,000 units it's just like it
doesn't work and you say okay well we
have to figure out a way to make a fully
integrated module that can help us build
something like this camera that cost
less than ten dollars or no one's ever
going to be able to have an auto camera
and so started this obviously we went
back to China and we try to solve these
problems so let's take a look it's
really small so around about March of
this year right we were talking to every
chip supplier known to man I can't say
the names because of all kinds of things
we've had to sign but this is what Gus
and I sort of came up with gusts through
this I was on the street in Hong Kong
and I called him on and they were going
back and forth he was drawing it up and
sending me different ones to my phone
and trying to figure out what needed to
be there and so this is the first
distillation of all of the pain and
experience of building Auto it wasn't it
just came out of nowhere right it was
okay let's go back and fix every little
thing that was an enormous pain in the
ass of the thing that we just did and
you'll notice some weirdness I've never
this has never been shown in public
before which is kind of fun there's two
tiny USB ports here is an early
iteration of the design there's not
there's not actually a big USB port and
there's also a barrel Jack right that
you can plug in and charge the thing
because we love barrel Jack's Auto has
this awesome barrel jack on the bottom
you know but the sort of core of it is
here like we know we need Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth we know we want this 813 SOC
we know that we need this 64 GB that's
gigabit not gigabyte and we know we need
RAM we need power management's and we
need a ton of things to connect to GPIO
is we need support of course for camera
sensors and so it's it's this experience
of building Auto that leads us to chip
and so you ask yourself why all winner
right all when is this amazing company
they have 700 employees they're based in
Zhuhai China they're basically like a
start-up semiconductor company and 2013
they built the largest number of tablet
SOC s in the world they build a hundred
million units
and when you think about price for
performance they are the best ARM
processor manufacturer on the plan if
you go on Taobao which is like chinese
sort of ebay right you can find
remanufactured units at these SS es for
less than a dollar and that's insane
because something really interesting has
happened recently in the last couple of
years there's a community called the Sun
she Linux community and they're a group
of people that have been working to
mainline when I say mainline ad drivers
support to these SS es in the Linux
kernel so that means if you could build
a computer around one of these old chips
it's a 55 nanometer process chip that no
one even uses anymore all are themselves
weren't even using it if you could get
that support in Linux and you could pair
it with the Wi-Fi and you knew what the
Wi-Fi was and again you kept it all
modern and you use modern Linux maybe
the Wi-Fi would just work that would be
awesome right and if you paired it with
some really really fast storage right
and you hooked it up directly to the SOC
right no memory controller you could
have really really fast boot times right
the theoretical minimum boot time for
chip and real experiments that I have
seen is around a hundred and forty
milliseconds right it's hard to boot a
hole in external but if you want to boot
directly to a C program you can boot
incredibly fast right and you do it on
top of an open source mainline you boot
as well if you want to run applications
and you boot which you good supports you
can boot even faster it's complete
madness and it's so if these little
choices like okay what kind of memory
we're gonna use because this is SOC if
you if you download the documentation on
our website which you can get which we
work with all one or two release so
people could actually do things with it
you're like oh it's got SDI oh right
it's got SDI oh so why don't we just use
an emmc which can actually connect to
the SD i/o bus and then we don't have to
worry about you know NAND we're leveling
and all these crazy things that you have
to do but then you start to think well
where's the Wi-Fi gonna go right the
wife I can't go on USB because then
we'll lose a USB port and we all know
you need two USB ports like one for a
keyboard and one for a mouse so the
Wi-Fi has to go
on the SDIO and what does that also mean
it means that no one can plug in the
wrong Wi-Fi it's on the board and if we
could just write the driver right make a
custom driver that was Emily the
open-source it and mainlined it it would
just work so you can start to see we
have this pattern right where we get up
sort of obsessed with this idea and then
we just sort of ignore how difficult
this might actually end up being and
that the things I'm talking about but
something I'll go right drivers we're
gonna you know integrate all these
things then we're gonna open source into
mainline and so we had to launch the
Kickstarter campaign right because we
had to not only buy a lot of these
things right we had to get a huge
community of people to help us you don't
add things to the Linux kernel by
yourself right
it takes dozens of people to change a
single line and then Lin us himself
usually has to say ok so you can see
it's just a just a cursory introduction
to how this works which is we've this
isn't some sort of you know magic that
we just divined this is a direct
response to the problems that we had
trying to build things and if you start
to work out through your head like hey
this is an early design I wonder how it
turned out the way that it did you start
to go and ask yourself like what are
people gonna use this for right and the
one sort of takeaway I want everyone
here to sort of have from this
conversation is I've talked to so many
people in electrical engineering and so
many people in the semiconductor
business and they have so much
incredible technology right that stuff's
getting smaller is getting cheaper and
faster but if you ask people what are
they gonna do with it
they always come look at you're really
strange right and they're like oh you
know it's it's faster it's cheaper it's
got more cores right well the thing that
makes this project a little bit
different than a lot of the projects
before it is that it was a board built
by the people that needed to solve their
own problem right where we had to go and
connect the dots so that it would be
useful when it came out the other end
and the definition of useful it's
evolved right when you call it the
world's first nine dollar computer and
people buy it and they expect the
computer
it has to work like a computer and that
means the Wi-Fi has to work perfectly it
means that any USB keyboard that you can
buy at any store or you can get a
goodwill has to work with it it means
that the audio has to work it means that
the graphics drivers have to work it
means that there has to be a GUI and it
has to be fast and there has to be a
browser that can run you know a WebKit
rendering engine and you've got to be
able to actually install games you
should be able to maybe play quake three
like it has to be a computer and so
every compromise that was made here was
made by how do we solve our problem of
building all this wacky stuff we want to
make and solve it at a price where we
can actually make things that people can
afford to buy and maybe stay in business
at the same time and then oh no we've
made a huge mistake we were so focused
on building things that we inadvertently
made the world's most affordable
computer now let's make sure it's
actually a computer right so what I
would say is if you're gonna design
something and talk about architecture of
a computer which is the sort of point of
this lecture it's not about making the
most elegant architecture it's not about
even making the cheapest architecture I
mean I could probably tell you that I
could make chip cheaper there's a lot of
really expensive connectors on there why
didn't we write it's about solving a
real problem right this is just a tool
and it's gonna be used for things and
the only reason it is the way it is
today is that we were trying to solve a
real problem it just happened to be our
own problem and a lot of other people as
we've seen that they have the same one
so with that I won't take questions
yeah very first LCD I would sign so it's
parallel it's parallel for reason
because the SOC only supports parallel
but also parallel LCDs are really
inexpensive if you use LVDS or DSi or
any of these things like there's all
kinds of stuff that needs to happen
where the cheapest display you can get
is maybe 25 bucks it's a really neat
thing the thing I'll say this is all 1s
an actual SOC architecture diagram
the usual thing about about the sort of
frameworks in these protocols is they're
all so none of them are really the same
right it's it is DSi but what flavor of
DSi what bit right and what what kind of
logic level power does it have and all
these are the things that you have to
answer and so what we've done is
basically use the cheapest less tough
least sophisticated thing where you can
actually buy five six dollar LCDs and
just plug them in and they just work
everything that you've managed to reduce
into this nine dollar ship when you are
buying those with existing products you
build up a system with multiple boards
what all was needed in order to how much
stuff did you replace with this and what
does that cost is B so this thing right
here this why I brought this you guys
could see it this is pretty much parity
between these two things so this is
storage Wi-Fi this actually doesn't have
Bluetooth for a number of reasons
storage Wi-Fi power battery charging
some GPIO breakout and the ability to
connect a camera and it's actually it's
actually discrete component tree we have
this board we have this compute module
which is a psalm and then we have a USB
Wi-Fi connector so it's actually three
discrete pieces and this thing is
actually quite difficult to assemble
this has to be hand saw or it can't be
wave soldered it's the component density
is actually super high it's got all
manner of challenges with it product
that you can buy this was a commercial
product that you could buy it actually
wasn't released when we designed this
which was really fun yeah and this is
all designed by us all right so it's
interesting that this has maybe 25
components on it you can buy it
to replace something that was partly
your old thing oh yes and what I'm
wondering is if you were doing nothing
but off-the-shelf systems and products
and add-ons costing what would the cost
event I mean depending on what you pick
right I mean there's so many different
single board computers but you're
looking at like for us it was around 60
to 70 bucks right doing like thousand
quantity which you know a few years ago
was
awesome right it was a like
game-changing price and the whole idea
and motivation to force the price down
was very specific right it was like how
do we make this cheaper right and it the
time it may have been unreasonable but
no one said as much and so it's the idea
here is that by forcing the price down
you would enable an entirely new kind of
person to use it in context of that 60
years that was at the BLM level sure
what fraction of your overall system
cost because you still have to worry
about housing yeah basically it's around
sixty to seventy percent of cost for
auto and what's crazy right is that the
same like the same chip here right as a
BCM 28:35 was actually used in the Roku
- right
so the Roku is a set-top box Roku -
retailed for $69 and you can buy them
today I think for even less than that so
it just didn't make any sense it was
kind of like wool what and it's to your
point right which is volume volume
volume like Amdahl's law maybe which is
that if you were taking something that
was only half or 60% of the original
parts cost you could reduce that to zero
and it would still cost nearly half of
what it cost previously yeah so in a
sense going all the way down to $9
probably could have gone to 18 dollars
instead of nine and come out just as I
mean it's yeah how much can you reduce
something if you still have to worry
about like this does not include the
actual camera image sensors or lenses or
stuff like that and so are sort of
thinking around that it's a great point
right is that you can make the computer
effectively free but what about all the
other stuff right and the thinking is we
don't know what kind of products people
want to make we don't know what kind of
projects people want to do but if you
make the computer as cheap as you
possibly can then people won't look at
an idea and say that will never make
sense unless you can sell 100,000 right
if you can sell 500 it'll make sense and
that's what excites us because you know
think about what happened in software
right where
now two or three people can get together
and they can have an idea and they can
build a thing and if people want it they
can scale it to an infinite number of
people that want to use it in the
hardware world we had this condition we
had a lot of people tens of thousands of
people that wanted it but the economics
forced us to actually not do it right
the you know in serial calls it this or
valley of death right where you can make
five hundred a thousand you can su can
filled orders for ten thousand but the
actual Bill of Materials and true
manufacturing cost doesn't make sense
until you make a hundred thousand and
you can't get across this sort of chasm
right and then you can go and you can
try and raise money and you talk to
investors and it just doesn't work right
because they're like well you know yes
the product would be retail Abul if you
could get there but you haven't
sufficiently proved demand because
you've only sold a thousand and come
back to me when the retailer's actually
commit to those orders and then you go
talk to the retailer's and they're like
well you know it's net 90 payment terms
and we're gonna see if we can sell them
before we'll pay you and just give sort
of stuck in the water just reduce it to
it's like the simplest thing and it
build out from there very hardware the
thing is we've specifically picked an
SOC that they'd used to build a hundred
million tablets and when you look at
what chip does it's very very similar to
what a tablet does but with no display
and no battery and so you know part of
this was working very closely with all
winner and going to China and sitting in
a room and eating this amazing garlic
crab but I was so good with the guy who
designed the SOC and you be like how do
we do this and he said okay we'll get my
application engineers we'll bring them
in and so you can get the guy who builds
the reference design that ended up
producing a hundred million tablets and
it helps also to understand that the way
that engine works is all winner gives
these independent design houses and
these factories pre made reference
designs they have like here is a tablet
TCB a here's the you know Schengen is
not quite open source they don't figure
out the licensing just yet but everyone
just copies everyone else and so our did
a really amazing thing and they said
let's just do a reference design so that
people can actually use our chips and
spread it out there and so there was a
time when you could get the same exact
tablet with a different package around
it from everyone and so it wasn't like
the crazy thing and this is the truth
the first chip that we ever prototype
worked right and it had the USB it had
two small USBs it just worked and I was
blown away right like it doesn't make
any sense
but then you start to wonder like well
the person I was asking these questions
he has done this a hundred million times
right and it turns out that you know the
hardware their enormous challenges
around how do you take a nine person
company and turn it into a multinational
organization in like 90 days that has
customers in 180 countries that's a
whole other conversation maybe I'll talk
you know somewhere else about but the
challenge for us is the software right
like how does NAND flash actually work
with this SOC well what if I told you
that the only existing functional NAND
flash driver is not open source or
recently open source is not documented
and only works with Android I only
worked Android and what if I told you
that there does not exist an open source
functional mlc nand driver in linux just
can't do it
right so we head back we've actually
building the drivers to make it possible
the hardware wiring everything up like
my favorite thing about electrical
engineers having worked in software for
so long is that they when you you get
the documentation which is usually
pretty good and then it does what it
says it's gonna do
unless it's broken right like it says
once it makes it in the white paper like
these are the pins you got to hook up to
turn it on
here are the voltages like I've built so
many API is in my life and maybe like
20% of time they do exactly what I say
they're going to do right so it really
is the software here that is taking most
of the work right we have I have chips
right here like why don't I just ship
all 50 thousand that we sold right now
well remember we promised it's a
computer and that means the software has
to be excellent it has to be perfect out
of the box as close as you can ever get
right we're the first
version 1 but it it has to just work and
that means we've had to go really really
deep in some of these things and when
you keep in mind that we're also just
just like we've done you know we were
able to build Auto because people did
these awesome things and they gave them
away and shared them like we're gonna do
this and it's already open source and
then the next person that comes here
next year and gives a talk about this
wacky Kickstarter project that they did
that turn into this crazy thing they're
not going to be talking about how
difficult it was to build power supply
or why the Wi-Fi doesn't work they'll be
talking about like something completely
different like well here we had to build
this camera sensor from scratch or like
all the other problems and so a big part
of this is let's move on right there's
thousands and thousands of engineers
that can build these boards that can
design these soces and yet we're still
all redoing the work over and over and
over again and so yeah I hope that
answers your question yeah the curse now
since its mainline Linux 4.2 is what we
shipped on the Alpha boards we have a
functional Debian build Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth works great we are now in the
process of mainlining everything so
display drivers audio drivers graphics
support all these different things and
so we're going to be releasing a we have
recipient other batch in December two
people that backed on Kickstarter and
those will ship with a the latest sort
of bleeding edge software and we've
built tools also that are open source
don't let people flash these things from
their computer Windows Mac Linux which
you guys can play with yeah is that not
answer your question well there's
another marketplace potential for this
sort of thing which is what people are
currently using
RINO's for it yeah that's how the boot
time is so important like what's really
cool about microcontrollers is that they
turn on instantly right it works in real
time and so if you can get the boot time
in the 100 millisecond neighborhood and
then you say hey I'm not going to use an
OS but I'm gonna use a real-time OS like
micro Linux or I'm gonna use free
artists or I'm going to use you boot
itself as an operating system
then you start opening up this whole new
idea where what if we could build really
inexpensive microcontroller style
applications but we could do it with
higher-level tools we could get the
speed of developing in Linux but the
price power efficiency and boot time of
microcontroller and that's an ultimate
thing where if people want to do it the
community will help us do it it's it's
an enormous project to pull that off but
it would be really cool so what which
specifically so we have got like four or
five different chips that are
interesting on here we can there's that
we have an entirely new device tree as
well so we actually create a DTD file
and we can do device for you overlays as
well and we've done all manner of things
so for example the Wi-Fi drivers are
completely new we've worked closely with
real tech to actually implement new
drivers using an L wireless that can do
things like connect to a network while
also creating one at the same time using
channel hopping and it turns out that
like these Wi-Fi chipsets they're
incredible right they just never get the
drivers to work and so all the things
that they can do never happen right so
that's that's one where Jason and our
team who is incredible and it's on the
Wi-Fi sort of Linux maintainer z-- group
is running that project and we're
basically saying like if we start from
sort of scratch here and we get the
Linux community behind it how good a
Wi-Fi driver can we make and in fcc
testing depending on the conditions
chips ability to communicate in via
strength and transmit and receive is
actually better than my MacBook which is
really wild and I think a lot of that
has to do with the radians and having a
chip antenna exposed and all that sort
of thing but it's still really cool to
see that you know we we say this a lot
in the office and it's and I don't have
ever said it public which is we're
trying to build things that are cheap
not shitty right it's cheap but it's
still really good right and that's
that's what we're trying to do with all
the drivers so Wi-Fi and Bluetooth this
one thing the other really really big
one which is just like implementing
stuff from four
principles so Boris and Maxine and
Thomas at free electrons who were
working with to do a lot of this
mainlining they're the guys that
maintain the Sun she kernel and are
actually working on the upstreaming work
boris and alex in our team and now alex
is background is as a experimental
particle physicist so he's used to like
you know really dirty low-level first
principle kind of work are building the
NAND we're leveling algorithms they're
solving the paired page problem in NAND
where you've got the you know you're
trying to basically cram more data into
these two cells and the actual you know
capacitance happening causes the data to
change and corrupt like these are the
kind of things that we're having to do
right and then things all we have an IO
expander as well right so how do we add
more GPIO s if you have an LCD attached
well we have a TI chip that communicates
over a serial bus that adds eight
interrupt driven GPIO s and that has a
pretty good Linux driver in it right but
we still need to have the modules and
have it all built in there as far as
look what else we have that's
interesting so the power management I
see a lot of the mainlining work was
already done on that so we picked these
chips for their Linux software support
and so that power management IC like but
the thing is like if you want to query
the battery life from the Linux desktop
like a gnome or using a gtk library it
doesn't show up so that's not good
enough
right if you have a battery attached to
chip and the battery life says it's a
hundred percent and then it dies that
does work so a lot of the drivers that
even already exists we're trying to take
them a little bit farther so so yeah to
that point right like here's a battery
pack this one from the auto assembly
just to sort of prove the point like all
batteries you buy that are life single
cell lipo sook wants them both to come
as a little jst connector on it that's
why chip has a jst there's no wire
crimping nothing like that you just take
this and you plug it in and then you
press this button and it's on right so
now you have a battery powered nine
dollar computer right but again so I had
this expectation of the battery right
yes we do engineering we do we make our
trellis or things and we all do this and
where you custom to saying that's
awesome the battery works but I know I
can't see the battery life in the UI
that's okay
no it's not okay it's not okay right
like we are we're just as important as
the end-user our work works the way that
we expect it's really important to us so
we're going to take the driver and take
it that one step further what is this my
computer is dead oh well
so yeah driver wise the other cool thing
you can do is you can look at our github
page and you can see all of the live
work happening and all the drivers that
we're building and the other thing too
is that we're not going to be able to
get every single functionality of every
single chip that is on chip because
there's just not time and we don't know
necessarily what people want to do and
this is why we have this kernel hacker
backer level was the idea that people
wanted to help us actually bringing the
board up and have these sort of things
so you can see on the forum there is a
trade off like someone look I don't want
to you are so I want an extra I squared
C bus it's like oh well you can just
change the drive device tree overlay and
just go for it
right yeah you've got new products and
so you can create a they could
basically support all these different
things your back to me system on module
right how did you decide to instead of
doing a 13 SOC on the and that's a a
song and instead decide to do it on this
little board with smaller number of my
oats and pins and if you had done this
differently would you would you make the
same choice again would you do it
differently what would you do
differently
based on what you know now I mean we've
made cheaper also you know like we could
have saved money with these headers like
you're getting out right these headers
are one of the most expensive components
on the board we had taken this thing off
and we spent that out there you know
extra 20 cents putting in a big plastic
case then maybe who wouldn't be so
worrisome about what it looks like right
it looks like a PCB and that's scary
so you know that was something that's
been talked about right it's like well
it's you know let's make this thing but
so if you buy this it's $49 or something
or $39 you buy it from Newark or
something you can't do anything with it
all right
yeah you build a border you have to buy
some kid or like this right here you
take it out of the box and it boots to
Debian right and like 45 50 seconds it's
the thing right away and for us thinking
about thinking about this sort of
problem we wanted it to be a developer's
tool but as as much like a product as
possible just like auto right this
philosophy is first demonstrated here
where this is a tool for artists and
hackers that want to experiment with
computer vision and photography right
but it looks like a product and that's
what we're trying for here is this is a
this is a tool people that want to make
stuff with computers but it's also a
computer and that's you know the thing
about having the headers and having
things the way that they are is really
about allowing people to experiment with
the least amount of set-up time right
it's point 100 headers you can use
jumper wires you just get things going
right away and that was the primary
motivation sure for all the integration
that you put in there it's still not a
standalone you do have to have
additional boards the camera image
sensor and so forth war is separate that
attaches by plugging into those headers
you're talking about I presume so you
can attach anything you want to the
headers the display adapters actually
snap onto the top right and so yes you
can add things that way but we sort of
when we decided to say it's the world's
first nine dollar computer there was a
very funny conversation of what is a
computer right and that was like we call
it computer things play games always for
things and that's why you know it has to
have the composite out it has to have
the full size USB because lo and behold
like you want to use this just this
Wi-Fi adapter on chip well you can just
plug it in right so okay distracted
the i/o interfacing to other boards to
share our daughter boards or expansion
with off-the-shelf things were you able
to adopt four standards in terms of the
form factor signal names and so forth so
that existing boards will plug in we
didn't we didn't actually there you know
sort of shield paradigm that exists in
every other board like I never really
liked the idea of shields because you
end up with this big stack of stuff and
like I like to make things that look
like something you can buy but the
community overwhelmingly wants this
right it's a great way to get started
with prototype and when they when we
found out people want to display
adapters we went that direction but
we've done something really interesting
which is the the BeagleBone project
which is in one of the better engineered
single board computers out there for a
whole host of reasons has this thing
called the Cape specification which is
the standard that you can actually
design things that snap onto it but the
thing that was really important to us
was having add-on boards that when you
put them together right I think Jef
Raskin who designed a lot of the
Macintosh has this rule first rule these
interface devout design is things should
do what people expect them to write and
if you take something that has an HDMI
jack on it and you plug it onto the
thing that you now know as your computer
and then it doesn't send the video
through HDMI you think it's broken right
we made I think it's broken like all you
got to run the shell scripts in this
folder download this update so what we
did is we've designed and this is stuff
we haven't quite released yet we'll have
this all be open source everyone can use
it we've designed a way where you can
actually recognize what hardware is
being attached and in the device tree
create a unique overlay for that and
load the kernel module so that when you
do like in the video when you pop chip
into pocket chip it does just turn on
right and when you add the display
adapter it just just works all right so
that's it's actually a whole engineering
effort on its own to define this
specification and then build the support
for the flash ROM that has to be on each
one of these boards what do you do for
Wi-Fi so it kind of surprises me most
about this overall you sleep normally
like you go on like a mouse or did you
you try to pray swipe my chips you see
that you know reasonably high quantities
those are look like the most expensive
parts again they can actually be more
than like a full like Armada subsidy
sure so first thing I said the beginning
we started this was you need to go to
Shenzhen right you need to go to the
source and we actually don't even do
components onboard here we do any actual
stamp whole module they call it right
that gets soldered on because buying
from this vendor all about economies of
scale right this is the same Wi-Fi
chipset that is used in every $99 or $79
tablet you can buy and Best Buy and we
went to them we said okay well we need
to buy 50 thousand right and it's very
inexpensive you wouldn't even believe
but the this is real tech will take
relationships yeah okay so and they're
awesome by the way like I've been when
you go to Taipei and you hang out with
the real tech they know how bad their
drivers are right they really know right
and I've talked to these guys and
they're and they're just like us like
they're super super smart and they're
ready to like fix it
but they just don't know how and so we
decided that look we need this register
level documentation we need this
information we need somebody we need an
F you know an application engineer to
help us with this they're like sure yeah
let's do it
it's kind of like no one ever thought to
ask like we've all sort of flamed
somebody on something about like man
yeah but the drivers are terrible and
you read the Amazon reviews like yeah it
doesn't work on Mac and there's like you
telling us doesn't work and you're
willing to fix it I'm like yeah just
give us the paperwork so they did and
much to Jason's credit like yeah it's
also the other reason that SDIO was the
right choice right because you don't
need the extra overhead of the USB
protocol and the extra chips that go
with it and if you look at a lot of
single board computers most of these
SSDs like they're you being used for
applications they weren't designed for
and so they don't actually have hub
controllers in them they have single
direct USB ports and so like you know
Raspberry Pi or peoplein they had
actually a hub chip in between the USB
port that you actually plug into and the
actual USB port on the SOC like the BCM
2835 has only one USB port
yeah it's interesting do you have the
FCC issues around this yes sir
we're working with bacl actually just up
the road yeah yeah they're awesome yeah
that's super cool we also do
certification in China and all that
stuff but like yeah it's again Jason is
the best like I've all right there's
always tooled I've always wanted to buy
when I was making stuff like I always
wanted a really awesome spectrum
analyzer like one of those giant Agilent
ones you know like you guys probably
have here in the lab I was like oh it's
even used it's like a couple thousand
bucks and I don't even really know how
to use it so I came in the office the
other day and there's like spectrum
analyzer and the chip is hooked up to
this thing and it's like yeah awesome
finally so yeah we're doing all that FCC
stuff which is actually not as bad as
you would think is a real tech stack
completely open-source so unfortunately
the firmware is not good get this wrong
cuz it's on the internet he worked on
the hack RF project so that's so so
software-defined radio is something that
we're all really interested in so I'm
I'm KK 6g h are on amateur radio so if
you guys want to hit me up yeah we're
really into that stuff and it you know
we're gonna try and experiment with
other chips we can use to do it we we
have the ability to make improvements
for their firmware and work with them to
do that but that is the problem with the
semiconductor business and I'd love to
come back in 24 months and say this is
not the case anymore is the IP right
there's the the IP sort of regimes that
exists and the fear of copying each
other and all these things that go on
which make perfect sense giving the
amount of capital expenditure that has
to happen to build these things in the
first place so it's I've been pushing to
for them to say just open your firmware
was not very good and then it's also
like the kind of things that we can do I
mean there we can get to a place where
we can write independent frames and we
can do cool stuff right but the other
thing about the the DSP chips which are
very cool and I played with they draw at
peak almost an amp right which is a
problem and you know we're also up
against this thing I'm waiting to see
what happens with the FCC where
we have tools to let people change the
way the Wi-Fi works but we can't
actually give them to the people which
really also makes me very nervous
but yes software-defined radio is the
best and we're working on that sort of
stuff sure
in complexes of the laptop cell phone
whatever people think in terms of
there's 10 X processor in here that's
running the applications running the
communication stack whatever often
there's at least one maybe a handful of
dedicated little micro controllers that
are interfacing with the gyroscopes
rates on ramadhir's or watching the
power of something independent of the
main CPU sure handling all the land
slurry stuff is this really just the SOC
processor inside or do you have other
sub delegated microcontrollers so it's a
question of its semantics right so I'm
not I'm not a trained engineer so I may
not know get the terminology right but
there are for example there is micro
code that runs in the ax B 209 which is
the power management IC it's a fully
programmable five rail power supply so
yes there is a microcontroller on-die
and also the TI chip it's also
programmable and you can set different
interrupts so there's a microcontroller
there but we do not have like a cortex
m0 floating around somewhere on the
board that you have to also worry about
managing the system is as close to bare
metal as one can get without getting too
dangerous and it's kind of also
something that's been discussed a lot in
the community and that you know I'm
reasonably pleased with our decision
that you know Gus and I've ever worked
out which was how do we want people to
interface hardware to chip and I'm a big
as the software guy I'm a big proponent
of you should use cereal like cereals
the way to go you shouldn't be doing
analog stuff like you know it's gonna be
isolated you know you're not gonna cause
problems and then we can have one set of
libraries that actually makes it work
and so that's kind of why you see things
the way that they are where it's
primarily you know serial things and not
analog so the thing is a contingent so
they answer that question like it's
actually the hardest part about
operating at scale is all of the
logistics and sourcing of all the
opponents and a lot of fun thing I've
learned about the semiconductor business
is like even if you're buying an i/o
expander or memory they store it as a
wafer right it comes off of TS out of
tsmc and it's all in a giant cage with a
bunch of wafers and they don't actually
package it until you ask for it and so
the lead times are crazy like eight nine
weeks to get something that's supposed
to be like a massively available part
you just can't get it like I went with
like literally cash to buy five thousand
pieces for prototyping they're like
we'll have it and so when you try and
buy a thousand pieces a thousand is that
weird intermediate number where they do
this thing called cut tape where you get
partial reels and inch engine you will
see you know people basically using
acetone to wipe the marks off of chips
and then rewrite them right because they
they assume that even the best quality
control at your SMT factory is not going
to actually evaluate each individual
chip and so something that we have done
as part of that right it's because these
lead times because of the amount of
money involved and because I don't want
to you know we none of us want to ship
something that doesn't work that'd be
the worst thing ever we go straight to
the manufacturer and so we say hey we're
gonna buy a ton of these things and I
you know we want these data sheets we
want these pre test inspection reports
and we try and control as much of the
supply chain as possible so that there
is not some guy in the middle who's you
know maybe wiping the labels off and
doing a lots or stuff quickie sure when
you're starting out you said that your
box art project had a crank like
Muybridge's thing were you aware of the
irony in coming to Stanford - talking
about Eadweard Muybridge names I was not
actually walk over there and also like I
mention look I could get the Wi-Fi to
work on my macbook and is the internet
invented here thing I was a lookout man
come on you alluded to that reference
okay so there were few Stanford students
here right but just show hands is this
something that anybody would actually
want to use Jovan's
yeah okay so I brought some yes
they're only nine bucks right and you
had to listen to me talk for so long so
one per person alright we open this day
one of the time so these are and they're
extra alpha chips right so all these
things I've talked about like you want
to change the drivers you want to help
with that sort of stuff this is your
chance so you can join the thousand
people out there already who are doing
this there you go all right cool pass
them around well thank you all so much
for inviting me this has been super fun
thank you
you